well good evening from London welcome to
Pi Morgan uncensored Harry and Megan's
claims about supposed racists and the
royal family have left a predictable and
poisonous Legacy for the last few years
we live in an age where grievances are
given the benefit of the doubt where the
establishment is Toxic by default where
my truth apparently means more than the
truth they knew the power their words
would hold and many people across the
world took their words at face value now
almost three years on Britain is still
dealing with the Fallout from this and
also concerns and conversations about
how dark his skin might be when he's
born what
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like hold up hold up there several
there are several conversations there's
a
conversation with you with Harry
about how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look
like and you're not going to tell me who
had the
conversation I think that would be very
damaging to them okay compartmentalized
concern that if he were
to
Brown that that would be a problem are
you saying that I wasn't able to follow
up with why but that if that's the
Assumption you're making I think that
feels like a pretty safe one you may
recall that I lost my previous job for
responding to these claims by saying I
didn't believe a word of it well Harry
and Megan have never provided any
evidence for that highly incend claim
it's not like they haven't had the
chance to after all they pumped out six
hours of self-indulgent Bild on Netflix
trashing Britain and the press for its
racism but didn't mention what they said
on Oprah Harry read 150,000 words of
family bashing poison in his Memoir
spare and T the TV studios to promote it
they didn't mention what they'd said to
Oprah Winfrey megum had a 12-part
podcast on Spotify didn't mention it
either it's like it never happened like
it
disappeared clearly neither of them gave
a damn about rawal protocol or family
privacy in fact they buil a whole
industry around violating their own
privacy and that of their relatives
instead of backing up those claims about
racism on their Relentless publicity
tour Harry did a sort of strange U-turn
didn't he a few months ago tried to
prect
they never said them it was it was us it
was the
media in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well the British press said
that right I did did Megan ever mention
they they
racist she said there were troubling
comments about concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially I wouldn't not having
lived within that family took him two
years to do that urn two years of the
royal family or a bunch of racists
flying around the world I was in America
through a lot that period and they all
believed it because it had appeared on
Oprah then he says I didn't never meant
to say anything about racism what are
you all talking about it's the beastly
media well now Harry and Megan's lick
spittle client journalist omed scobby
the man who lied about his age said he
was 33 when in fact he was 38 bit older
now said he never used private jets and
then got reminded of an Instagram
picture of him the week before he denied
that this week showing him on a private
jet the man who said that I have regular
phone calls with quen ciller regular
phone calls never had one phone call
with Quin killer in my entire life I'd
like to but she doesn't call well scobby
is back with a spiteful Li filled new
book that's poured fuel on the Flames he
says that Megan wrote private letters to
King Charles naming two Royals who she
accuses of taking part in those
supposedly troubling conversations about
Archie skin color scobby initially said
he knew the names but couldn't legally
report them but of course he could have
done outside of the UK he could have
done it in America if he wanted to where
the book is published could done it
anywhere but he said he never names
names which is another of his lies and
yet overnight they were sensationally
revealed suddenly out of nowhere in the
Dutch version of sco's book journalists
had been sent copies and the book was
briefly onale
in bookstores before being suddenly
withdrawn in a dash by the Publishers
scob initially said it was a translation
error which didn't really make any sense
because how do you mistranslate
names they're either there or they're
not the publisher now says wasn't
translation it was simply an
error but how did that error happen how
is there an entire different version
appearing in a Dutch edition of this
book the consequence of the error is
that millions of people online around
the world now know the Royals are again
being implicated in what I think is a
completely baseless claim of inferred
racism there is again massive
speculation about who the people are who
were supposedly making comments about
Archie skin color which is incredibly
unfair to all the royal family they've
all been tired with this brush now for
years well I'm going to end all this
nonsense because frankly if a book is on
the streets in Holland available to
Dutch people containing names that omed
scobby the lick spittle scribe for the
Juke and dutches of Sussex the man who
you may remember denied they had any any
involvement in the last book and so did
Megan do you remember nothing to do with
it but then in court many months after
the book was published under oath she
had had to admit she had emailed her
AIDS briefing notes for when they met
scobby so she was one of his primary
sources on that first book now again
we're being told she had nothing to do
with this and maybe she didn't and maybe
we should be believing om scobby when he
says he did not ever write these names
down in any draft of his book it just
somehow popped up in the Dutch version
of the
book How I I've written 10 books I think
it is now I've never had a version of my
book pop up in a foreign Edition that
contained unbelievably damning
allegations about two of the most famous
people in the world and I had nothing to
do with it and didn't know how it got
there and nor did anybody else how does
it get there Omid surely you as the
author me you must be furious right you
must be demanding heads roll
and you want names don't you ironically
omed about who did this to you who smed
your reputation as an author I would
omed I'd want to know right now
especially if I was trying to convince
the world that I had nothing to do with
it myself and I'd never ever put these
names in writing and maybe some lawyer
had come along and told me not to I mean
that couldn't possibly have happened
because you've given us your word and as
I've established so far in this
monologue your word is your bond and
should be taken as sacr saint
well I'm going to cut through all this
crap I'm going to tell you the names of
the two senior Royals who are named in
that Dutch version of the book because
frankly if Dutch people wandering into a
Bookshop can pick it up and see these
names then you British people here who
actually pay for the British royal
family you're entitled to know too and
then we can have a more open debate
about this whole farog go because I
don't believe any racist comments were
ever made by any of the royal family and
until there is actual evidence of those
comments being made I will never believe
it but now we can start the process of
finding out if they ever got uttered
what the context was and whether there
was any racial intent at all like I say
I don't believe there was the Royals who
are named in this book are King Charles
and Katherine princess of
Wales we'll join him in now is the Royal
editor of the Sunday Times Roy Nika who
just discovered I was going to do that
Royal biographer Tom bow who also just
discovered going to do that and the
professor of black studies at birmingh
University kahindi Andrews but first the
Dutch Royal journalist Rick IAS who has
read the damning excerpt because he's
seen it in the Dutch version um let me
talk to you Rick first of all uh when
you first saw what appeared in the Dutch
version what what did you
think well I wouldn't think I would have
some big scoop because I I was thinking
that everyone in the whole world would
have the same copy except it would be in
English so I didn't I wasn't aware that
it was such a big thing how do you think
of course it is a big thing that their
names are in it but um everyone would
would have the same same copy isn't it
usually well I didn't I I couldn't work
out in my rational head why you should
know what those names were but British
people shouldn't so that's why I've said
them um and to repeat I don't believe a
word of these racism claims never have
done I've seen no evidence to suggest
they're true I think it was an ugly
smear and now at least we can have a
public debate about it and people can
say what they really want to say about
it but from your
perspective how do you think these
paragraphs appeared in the Dutch version
if omed scobby the author insists as he
has done that he had nothing to do with
it never put these names in writing
never supplied a draft with those
names first of all I want to say um
after your track record appears um it
would be would be very uh unimpressed if
you didn't mention these names so uh
well done because you're the first one I
think on TV that that's doing that um
well I to be honest with you I don't I
don't understand why why journalist
wouldn't I haven't understood why we
haven't so far because the moment a book
is published and available to people on
the streets of another country
containing these names um you know I
don't I don't even know if these are the
two names of the two people that mean
marle originally with Harry claimed made
these comments we don't know um but we
do know they've appeared in the book a
version of the book and it's om Miss
sc's book and we do know that under oath
Mega Mark admitted that she she
conspired in his last book as one of his
sources so let's wait let's wait and see
how this plays out but again just to
come back what do Dutch people in the
media think has happened
here well I don't think Dutch people
really care about it but because it's
it's it's the the US royal family in
this case that is uh is involved not
even the British royal family actually
because people don't believe it I think
um but the other hand how did it end up
in the book I think it's it is in the
way omad is describing it um it was not
in the manuscript what is the manuscript
is it the the final version that you
hand in in your at your publisher in
that case it was an earlier version and
it got erased in all the other versions
all over the world except for that tiny
little country the Netherlands that has
been overlooked uh maybe someone
overlooked the Netherlands to send us a
memo the publisher or maybe the
publisher forgot to do it I don't know
well it's very mysterious let me go to
another seasoned author Tom bow you've
written many books have you ever known
as situation Tom where a version of your
book has appeared in a foreign version
containing paragraphs you knew nothing
about that contain bombshell Revelations
it's impossible and also more to the
point you also complained that the
French translations were wrong too I
mean the problem with scobby is everyone
is getting it wrong what he wrote of
course he can't probably remember what
he wrote himself because it's so full of
Fab well I'm not saying he's lying about
having no involvement in this I'm just
saying I'm just saying generally he's a
terrible liar he's a terrible liar uh we
know that from his own statement about
the briefing from Jason K on which Megan
gave him we know he's a liar and I think
he's fabricated a lot in his book and he
lied when he said he didn't have Megan's
help in this book clearly he was briefed
by Megan's people from California he
says they share mutual friends right but
those friends would not be allowed to
cooperate with him without permission
exactly before this is all this his book
again is Megan's voice why is she
decided to launch Another War a battle
against the raw family that's for her to
explain but she hasn't dissociated
herself from um have you ever thought
that there was any racial intent any
comments made no no I mean the whole
this actually explained in my Megan book
very clearly it was a very very early on
in Harry's relationship with Megan he
goes for tea to clarence's house he's
sitting there with King Charles Prince
Charles then and Camila and they
eventually discover who is is dating and
all the rest of it and Camila very as a
joke just says I wonder what your baby
will look like will he he or she have
ginger hair it's just the normal and
when that that originally came out it
had nothing to do with racism as Harry
himself admits it was all to do with a
perennial problem what will your baby
look like if it comes from different
parents I just thought it was incredibly
disingenuous of Harry after two years of
feverish racism
slurs he then said he then said oh we
never meant to infer racism no no the
whole point is in the got her interview
that he comes on to the program after
Megan has spoken and says no she's wrong
it all happened long before she was
pregnant it happened right at the
beginning of our relationship it was
just a normal tea conversation two years
before exactly and so Megan had lied I
mean there was 17 lies she uttered in
the Opera interview that was one of her
lies and that is the problem he's now
hoist by it but the real problem he
caused enormous damage and scob damage
and scobby to get some money and all the
rest stirs it again and again again but
this time yet again is definitely with
Megan's approval okay Roy look you
didn't know I was going to do the naming
of these two people I don't want to get
you involved in that directly you're a
royal correspondent but on the wider
picture this book is getting more and
more attention it's now front page news
of many papers it clearly has a lot of
damaging Revelations it follows a
familiar pattern from his first book all
the main Royals are awful Jan dutches
are susex are Angelic and weren't they
treated so badly um how's significant is
this book is it going to actually have
any real effect do you think well it's
interesting you say it's full of
damaging Revelations and Bombshells
because actually from what I have read
so far it's just full of Ed's own highly
partisan views and opinions rather than
fact-based damaging bomb allegations
that I think uh a lot of people thought
were going to be unveiled with real
proper evidence behind them and I have
to say I've been asked about the book a
lot this week
and it's just felt quite predictable and
of course it was always going to get
lots of traction because it's Omid it's
the Royals but it just feels once again
like finding Freedom a very one-sided
partisan the rest of the roal family
awful har and Megan men of roses and I
think actually the British public and a
lot of The Wider public are able to sort
of decide for themselves which camp
they're in how much they believe how
much they don't I mean you've talked
about already this week the things that
Omen has said about you that aren't true
he's he's he really not a fan of the
Sunday Times coverage I've read and he
had a wi and a moan about my William
interview knocking off trooping the
color from the front page we never put
trooping the color on the front page and
so on and so forth so I think is it
going to be hugely damaging I think
it'll whip up a storm predictably you
know to get publicity and I feel that
possibly something around these names
could be to do with publicity but I
don't think it's going to have real
lasting damage because I don't think
people are going to believe every all
his opinions right and that and and they
shouldn't by the way from my experience
but in terms of I guess the the family
relationships here particularly how
and his father we were reading signs of
potential reproach more would they come
to sandre I got to say I think I've got
more chance of being at sandre and the
mega Marco pulling my story crackers
they'd like to yeah um it was your story
yeah um but none of this is going to
help because there is this belief which
may or may not be true in the case of
this book that's I don't know right but
we know in the first book Mega marle
said she had nothing to do with it and
then under Roth had to admit she did if
if it turns out the same has happened
here and she's authorized friends to
help him and give him stuff because
let's face it this exchange of letters
between Charles and and Megan marle only
one of them can have told people about
that and Charles is not the kind of guy
that's going to be telling people about
a letter like that which makes me think
it's her and her friends or somebody has
gone to scob we'll wait and see but if
that is the case this is going to be
very damaging to the ongoing trust
issues between Charles and Harry well
trust is the key issue and I think that
was something I I touched on in that
piece about them saying we wouldn't
decline an invitation to spend time with
the family the problem is as As You Just
Right rightly Said imagine what a whole
Christmas at Sandringham um would would
produce in terms of potential you know
potential future content and I think
looking at you know the phone call
between Charles and Harry and Megan um
around Charles 75th birthday it was
briefed before it happened and it was
briefed after and I think if you can't
even have a private phone conversation
that isn't brief before and or after I
honestly wouldn't trust if I if that was
someone in my family after what they've
done yeah repeatedly repeatedly
repeatedly I wouldn't trust them as far
as I could throw them trust is the issue
and that's not changing anytime soon
let's go to kahindi Andrews be waiting
uh patiently here hendy we've talked a
lot about uh race issues over the years
but specifically here there is no doubt
that when they went on Oprah Winfrey uh
two years ago they made a series of
allegations directly inferring racism by
senior members of the royal family which
they've never produced evidence for and
which two years later Harry said oh we
didn't mean racism we meant unconscious
bias and so on do you not
feel that that is incredibly damaging to
people like you who constantly fight
battles for racial equality racial
Justice you know try and and fight
proper battles about this is it not
incredibly damaging to that when someone
of their profile tries to pretend what
they said to Oprah Winfrey was not what
it
was well no I mean I think the
allegations when they came out we all
kind of believed it it wasn't something
that seems completely outrageous also
I'm not sure what evidence you could
have and actually if you listen to the
clips they're clearly trying not to say
the names because they know the names
are going to cause this massive storm I
think the bigger problem with the whole
way this has been has been portrayed is
Oprah is shocked everybody
shocked no black person I know was
shocked that this came up in a
conversation in the Royal Family and the
bigger problem here really is that
actually it isn't about racist Royals
it's about the the royal family is
racism it is a symbol of white suemy
that's the bigger problem talk about
this now is completely because they're
white no not because they're white not
because they're white because they are
exclusively where is the evidence of
them being white supremacist they link
back to the they link back to
colonialism why do we even idea that a
country like Britain which is incredibly
diverse an Empire which was more diverse
is led by this almost exclusively white
family into the 21st century I'm sorry
that is so you're judging them by their
by their skin col issue of racism so
you're just to be clear you're judging
them by their skin color not the content
of their characters no I'm say I'm
saying their skin color is Not an
Accident it is not an accident that Mega
Mar they can't helping white accident
she she's run out of the they're
white I'm white we can't help our skin
color it's not it's not about their skin
color it's about what it represents the
idea that the that King Charles is the
king of my family is from Jamaica which
is 90% black people and the king of the
head of state of Jamaica is this is the
King Charles it's ludicrous that is a
ludicrous thing in the 21st century but
that is what I'm saying symbol of white
supremacy have a vote I couldn't care
less if it was Kate listen the countries
like Jamaica will have votes and they
can deci having a vote it's about the No
No but point is you there are countries
choosing there are countries like
Jamaica choosing whether they want to go
independent that's absolutely a
democratic right you don't have to have
a
the fact that's a choice the fact that's
a choice in the 21st century tells you
there's a big problem I'm understand do
you think anyone anyone in the royal
family just to be clear anyone in the
royal family as far as you're concerned
is a white supremacist simply because
they're white and they're part of the
royal family this what I'm saying is
this the royal family like the police or
like universities or right work they are
they are institutions of white supremacy
it's not about the individuals it's
about what they do it's about their role
in the world that's the real case the
royal family should be gone it should be
abolished shouldn't exist if we're
talking about anti-racism I really
couldn't get less which which Royal said
what because that's not that actually
distracts what if they didn't say it at
all we accept what if they didn't say it
at all but the whole world has been LED
for two three years to believe that they
did what about that scenario like I said
like I this doesn't like for me it
really doesn't matter if they said it or
not not about individual people say it's
not they are all racist they are as in
an institution which is racism which is
one of the primary symbols of racism you
know sometimes I think he's a bit
surprising that K I think I going to say
sometimes you know when when your
default position which it always is by
the way is that everyone's a white
supremacist if they got white skin color
until they can prove otherwise it is
your default position it is your default
position you know know what I that's
always been your default position I said
the the institution any white people in
any position of authority power anything
they're all white supremacist
it do beg the question why you want to
live in a country like this if like
the I should I should I can go home back
to Jamaica unforunately that head of
state is the King the same problem I
can't get from you can go where the hell
you like I'm just saying why why
honestly why why stay in a country you
believe is Led in every pillar of the
establishment and Society by white
supremacist makes no sense to me cuz the
reality is that that's the world I I
didn't choose the world that is world
that I inhabit and I will just stress
I'm not saying that all white people are
white supremacist I actually think when
we think about racism that individual
racist it's the worst way to think about
it think about the systems think about
the institutions and the royal family is
exclusively white for a reason it is the
head of the So-Cal Commonwealth British
Empire for a reason it is a direct
connection to the Colonial history that
this country loves so much it is the
Premier symbol of white supremacy get
those actually not exclusively white
coms it's not exclusively white because
the Dutch is exclusively I said of susex
is not white what she did do was she
entered the the r she launched a grenade
of uh racism allegations and has ever
since stayed silent about those let let
them let them run around the
world I mean that to me came into the
family and her black so so much of an AF
everybody lost their minds that in it
way is a form of racism actually in my
view what she's done um but we'll see
we'll see how this all plays out now
because i' I've decided to name the two
people named in the holl version of his
book let's let's see how this plays out
let's see whether Mega marle and Harry
were involved with Scooby's book let's
see what scobby and his involvement in
this offending paragraph and naming was
let's just see how this all plays out
and let's give the members of the royal
family that they besched collectively
let's give them the chance to properly
respond because I don't believe a word
of it anyway kahindi uh it's always good
to talk to you thank you very much Tom
good to see you Roy thank you very much
indeed